for
right good evening
everybody evening managing
Welcome to our first cabinet meeting of
2024 fire alarm procedures if the fire
alarm is activate evate the offices VI
the stairs please do not use the lifts
assemble in hly square on the green
officers will assist you and advise when
it's deemed safe to return to the
chamber please switch off or turn to
silent your mobile phones and do not
make or receive calls while the meeting
is in
progress please note this meeting is
being live streamed for members of the
public the meeting will also be recorded
and will be subsequently available on
the internet um does anyone intend to
film the
meeting following members have asked to
speak under Council procedure rule 20.1
item six councelor rattigan item eight
councilors Davis rattigan and wing and
item nine Davis and councelor rattigan
do any other members wish to speak under
20.1 no thank you
everybody's here so there are no
apologies does anyone have any interest
to declaring the items of business on
the agenda this
evening thank you minutes of the
previous
meeting which was held on the 14th of
December 2023 copy was attached to the
agenda pack I propose proposed we take
the ministers red do I have a
seconder councilor Alan members agree
agree thank you
you this evening's performance will be
led by Council Yates who's going to kick
off with item for the treasury
management strategy statement
Etc thank you
leader I'll uh make sure to drink a bit
of water in between the speaking tonight
um this report is required in accordance
with the sfur code of practice on
Treasury management this report includes
the council's climate Net Zero Target
and I'm pleased to report that this is
started SE fruition with 2 million pound
in the Standard Chartered fixed term
deposit during the 23 24 year and an
option to continue within the next 24 25
year Investments are referenced against
the United Nations sustainable
development goals including tuber not
limited to climate change Health
financial inclusion and education this
Fund in particular represents a 4 and a
half% fixed returns to thanet taxpayers
over this in uh period of investment
this report also covers our C Capital
spending and financial plans and its
treasury strategy backed by penti
indicators and limits this report also
presents for approval of the council's
minimum Revenue provision policy Capital
strategy investment strategy and non-
treasury Investments report for the next
financial year this report was
considered by the governance and audit
committee on 29th of November 2023 2023
I move the
recommendations thank you Council y have
a second councel K any comments
members you I'm going to read the
recommendations into the record because
I think particularly for people viewing
online that is helpful um cabinets asked
to note make comments as appropriate on
the report and annexes including each of
the key elements listed below a the
capital plans credential indications and
limits for 20124 25 to 2026 27 including
the authorized limit credential
indicator b the minimum Revenue
provision MP policy see the treasury
management strategy for 2024 25 to 2026
27 and the treasury indicators D the
investment strategy for
20242 contained in the treasury
management structure strategy including
the detail criteria the capital strategy
for
20242 and the non- treasury Investments
report for
20242 and to recommend this report and
annexes including each of the key
elements listed above to council for
approval do members agree agreed agreed
thank you members item five the 2024 to
28 me medium-term Financial strategy CC
y thank you leader uh the medium-term
financial strategy provides an
integrated view of the whole of planic
District council's finances this covers
the general fund revenue and capital
budgets alongside the H revenue and
capital budgets setting out a strategic
approach to these risk to be managed and
policies to be applied over the period
of 24 to 2028 it also covers indicative
budgets and the council tax for the
medium term whilst the report is focused
on the council's future financial
position it was helpful to look back at
past circumstances as highlighted below
clearly there's great uncertainty as to
what form local government finance will
take over the me term let alone the
shape of the macro environment
nonetheless the council continues to
prudently identify longer term budget
savings which can be implemented if and
when necessary to close the forecast
budget gaps as presented within the
report the key assumptions in place
under this uh cental forecast is that
the reform of the local government
financial system is implemented in 2026
to 27 resulting in funding allocations
being broadly the same in 2025 to 26
including one final year the new homes
bonus at
$228,000 that business rates baselines
and related compensation funding remain
at current levels and are increased by
inflation that no core grant funding uh
RSG new homes bonus or otherwise
allocated from 2026 27 onwards with a
consequent 1.3 65 million loss of
funding uh reset of the business rate
systems in 26 27 leading to a loss of
1.6 million in accumulated growth other
key assumptions applied include
continued High inflation and stagnant
economic growth at least into 25 to 26
consequent 3% pay award assumed in the
later years of the mtfs financial
pressures on the homelessness service
remain high that the council tax
referendum limit is 3% in 25 26 and then
2% afterwards and the council sets
council tax at these limits as per
Government funding assumptions the
council tax base grow grows about 2% in
in each of the following three years of
the mtfs and significant borrowing uh
repayments associated with the financing
of the capital program including budget
provision for the electrification of
refuse collection vehicles I move the
recommendations thank you councilor Y is
there a seconder councelor
Duckworth okay members any
comments so members have been asked to
approve the 20 2428 mtfs be agreed and
referred to council for approval do
members agree thank you move on to item
six which is the HRA budget
20242 Council Yates thank you lader next
year's H budget is underpin underpinned
by 7.7% increase in rents next year
representing CPI as at September plus 1%
the majority of which will be covered by
increased benefit or Universal credit
payment to our tenants this rent
increase is needed to continue to drive
the H to a balanced and sustainable
financial position and also to finance
our ambitious house building program and
housing investment plan it is worth
saying and highlighting that we have no
rents that are above the lha rent
through consultation with the portfolio
holder there has been a change in the
budget since the draft was presented to
Cabinet in October this being the
creation of a hardship fund this sees
£30,000 being allocated to assist those
tenants on a low income who may be
struggling to meet the rent or associate
service charges levied the the criteria
of the fund will be developed and
published by the tenant and leaseholder
team to ensure these specific tenants
are supported I move the
recommendation thank you councelor Yates
have a second on councelor album and
before we go to 20.1 I'm going to invite
councelor Whitehead as the portfolio
holder to make her
comments thank you councilor Yates and
thank you
leader to explain our rent structure and
context of the HRA budget further it's
important to look at what we currently
deliver in ter and what we need to
deliver in terms of
capacity at TDC we use two forms of
rental rate within our general housing
stock social rent and affordable rent
our version of affordable rent is very
different from the central government
definition which generally defines
affordable rent as being up to 80% of
private rental
rates for thanet that would be far from
affordable so we use a dual layer
definition our affordable housing which
I tend to refer to as genuinely
affordable housing is clusters up to 80%
of private rent but not to exceed local
housing allowance rate which
historically for this area never meets
80% of the private rental market simply
our affordable housing will never go
above local housing
allowance the vast majority of our
housing stock is at Social rent social
rent is a lower rent than affordable
rent and much lower than private Market
rent at a social rent a three- bed house
would cost approximately £452 and 52 per
month at TDC affordable rent it would
cost approximately £74 per
month on the private Market three bed
homes are currently renting at between
£1,100 and
£1,600 per
month the current local housing
allowance rate for a three bed house is
£
meaning that both forms of rental that
we offer would be more than covered by
housing benefit and the housing element
of Universal Credit making both
accessible for even our most vulnerable
or disadvantaged
residents it is worth noting that the
vast majority of individuals who rely on
lha to afford their housing are
currently trapped within the private
rental
market this is one of the principal
reasons for creating and adopting our
accelerated delivery program as the most
disadvantaged residents in terms of how
affordability and therefore cost of
living are currently within the private
sector to help them as we have helped
those within the council portfolio we
have to expand our
provision in April we are also likely to
see a significant increase in the lha
rate in all likelihood this means that
even our affordable rental will fall
within the mid-range of
lha the council portfolio currently
consists of 3,460
properties only 160 5 of these are at an
affordable rent the rest are at Social
rent the vast majority of our residents
have access to support with rental costs
through housing benefit or the housing
element of Universal Credit and
therefore any increas is covered via
benefits in those
cases each year councils are permitted
to raise rents with the addition of 1%
to the Consumer Price Index this
September CPI stood at
6.7% which means that we are permitted
to raise rents by 7.
7% we have heard from 19 other councils
regarding their rent increase this year
all are planning a 7.7% increase the
regulat social housing has also
confirmed the 7.7% limit for
2425 last year Council increased rents
across both 10 years at
7% 2-year inflation stands at 16.8% and
we are potentially increasing rent by
14.7% across 2 years so we are currently
2.1% below inflation over 2 years even
with a 7.7% increase this
year our tent and Lease holder
Representatives have been briefed on the
potential for 7.7% increase they were
very supportive as they are aware of the
need to expand and support those
residents in the private sector and also
supported further expansion of our
in-house temporary
housing although these decisions are
made yearly it is important to remember
that they have a cumulative effect
choosing not to increase rent this year
would not only reduce housing funding
for this year but would reduce it in
perpetuity as we cannot choose to raise
the rent to make up for it the next
year as discussed earlier on it is also
important to remember that this increase
apart from households that receive no
assistance with housing benefit or the
housing element of Universal Credit does
not come from residents Pockets it will
be paid by central government as the
increase is still well below the full
rate of local housing allowance
I've put forward an option that I
consider provides the best outcome for
both current tenants and all residents
in terms of growing housing
provision increasing at 7.7% across both
forms of tenure but providing a support
fund to ensure that any households on a
lower income whose increases not paid
via benefits are not impacted allows us
to support more residents in the private
sector grow the portfolio further and
does not disadvantage current tenants
the predicted net cost of this op in
2425 is
£30,000 we would administer and
determine support assessing those who
have no access to benefits and on a low
income as eligible for support the fund
could be used in a range of ways to
support households facing financial
hardship it is absolutely essential to
consider the fact that our most
vulnerable residents currently are those
who are homeless struggling to afford
private rent and in insecure
tendencies in only four months we have
been able to add 123 extra properties to
our portfolio to support these residents
but to continue supporting others in
vulnerable positions it is vital that we
both maintain and grow our
portfolio I'm more than happy to take
any questions thank
you thank you councelor Whitehead and
speaking out 20.1 I have councelor
rattigan thank you very very much um I
appreciate the affordability for
is really important but I am concerned
that the H deficit is still quite big
and obviously with uh us ping large
amounts of new homes isn't this going to
push us further in the future into
deficit um on my concern is then we
going to sort of a catch 22 where we're
going to sort of increase huge amounts
of uh more
debt just to
clarify in terms of the deficit are you
suggesting that we should increase rent
further because we're Limited at CPI
plus
one oh sorry um I mean OB understand
that you can't but obviously we need to
look at ways within that budget of been
able to sort of balance that out up so
there isn't you know that we're we're
running on an even Gil because I'm just
concerned with more houses and more
costs how will that in the future then
be be covered
in terms of the new acquisition
strategy
we do a thorough business Cas th words
business case testing on every single
development that we take
on that includes Financial testing to
ensure that it will be profitable and
therefore doesn't impact in terms of the
deficit we also have very healthy
reserves in terms of Housing and
we're determined to make sure that
although we have a duty to grow the
portfolio we don't impact on tenants
andly hence the addition of the hardship
Grant I'm more than happy to pass over
to councelor Yates and Bob on that
point yeah thank you councelor whad um
just to um add one point to that in
terms of the new program um every every
report that comes to um cabinet
recommending uh properties either
construction or acquisition in that
program uh comes with um a detailed
analysis of the impact on the business
plan um though generally those um those
plans show a deficit in the initial
years uh moving into Surplus in the
later years in the long term so 30 years
over the lifetime of the business plan
um there there um there is significant
Headroom in the in the revenue budget um
and at that point it will move it will
move into Surplus in the long term um in
the short term we've set aside and this
was U agreed in the paper to council
that um established this program we've
set aside a £300,000
budget uh to cover the def the initial
deficits in the initial years of all of
those
developments okay okay I think that's
been answered um any other comments
members
okay so it's been moved and seconded
that the H budget for 2024 25 be
recommended to council for approval and
that the revised housing revenue account
Capital program for 202 2428 be
recommended to council for approval do
members agree agree thank you and we
move on to item seven which is the
council tax based calculation report 202
2425 and we go back to council Gates
thank you leader this report presents
for approval to council the council tax
base for 2425 which has increased by
1.52% on the previous Financial year
this report makes a number of
recommendations on the um and these are
bullet points empty homes discount for
properties unocc un unoccupied and
unfurnished on determining the long-term
empty premiums and on
discontinuing and on discontinuation of
the the council tax class D discount for
properties and undergoing structural
alteration and or major repair these
changes will be effective from 1st of
April 2024 and this report forly
approves the council tax reduction
scheme effective 1st of April 2024
finally the report includes the
application of a 100% council tax
premium on properties that that are
unoccupied and furnished often referred
to as second homes Class B properties
this is applicable from 1st of April
2025 in line with the 11 in up and
regeneration act
2023 all of these changes will increase
our capacity to support those that are
most disadvantaged in the in our
district I move the
recommendations thank you councilor y
secondar councelor
Kean members any
comments okay I should read the
recommendations in
full so cabinets being asked to one
determine for the financial year 20242
the empty homes discount for properties
unoccupied and unfurnished Class C
Properties remains at % so the council
tax will be payable in full on these
properties to approve the district
council's tax base for 20242 as
46,4
54.6 and the tax base for the towns and
parishes in the council's administrative
area as set out in the table at appendix
2 to determine the long-term empty
premium for properties that have been
left empty and substantially unfurnished
for periods of one year but less than 5
years a long-term empty premium to be
charged at 100% And for periods of 5
years but less than 10 10 years a
long-term empty premium to be charged at
200% and for periods of 10 years or more
a long-term empty premium to be charged
at
300% fourthly to formally approve the
discontinuation of the council tax class
D discount for properties undergoing
structural alteration and or major
repair effective from the 1st of April
2024 fifthly to formally approve the
council tax reduction scheme as set out
in the report effective from the 1st of
April
2024 and lastly to formally approve the
application of a 100% council tax
premium on properties that are
unoccupied and furnished often referred
to as second homes or Class B properties
applicable from the 1st of April 2025 in
line with the leveling up and
regeneration act 2023 do members agree
great thank you
members and we move on to item eight
which is 2024 fees and charges councelor
Yates thank you leader fees and charges
were presented to Cabinet in October as
part of the main budget report in order
to support the 2425 budget setting
process the review of fees and charges
commence in the early summer and
proposed fees and charges were then
received by cabinet in October for
recommendation these projections were
based on a broad 8% increase which is
based on inflation as of June 2023 this
was expected to generate additional
income of around £350,000
work undertaken looked to ensure that
charges would remain competitive and the
income budget expectations were
realistic allowing us to manage existing
shortfalls of actual income against
budget expected income growth from fees
and charges for the forthcoming year
excluding excludes items such as
selective licensing on street parking
and specific growth items covered
elsewhere in the budget since this
report was presented in October
inflation has reduced to nearer 4% and
as a result with we are taking the
opportunity to review our fees and Char
charges where possible bringing these to
nearer 5% um and the budget for 2425 now
includes the allocation of
£16,000 to help facilitate this as a as
a result of this work it's not been
possible to provide the revised Annex to
this report this evening and this will
be brought to cabinet at the end of
January for considerations I move the
recommendations thank you councel y you
have a second now councelor
Whitehead and we have speakers under
20.1 first of which is councelor
Davis thank you chair leader um I will
be as brief as I can this evening
because I do understand that we've got
another uh bite to look at this overview
and scrutiny next week so I just wanted
to clarify a couple of items um on page
81 of the report under under uh revenues
it refers to Maritime Revenue uh
inflation based increases in charges are
anticipated as at last October oober
should generate
164,000 is that purely on inflation
based increases cuz it's very close to
the figure that we were hoping for which
was a speculative figure hoping for
trade cuz um Matt or Rec all answering
that is this a separate figure can we
could we know
please this is purely based on inflation
it's it's nothing to do with it's
literally an inflationary increase
across the board so they've all been
reviewed and benchmarked against other
um Port Authorities and so on and so
forth so thanks Matt so it is purely
inflation thank you for clarifying thank
you
leader councelor
rattigan uh just a quick one um it's
nice to see that obviously that you've
been able to reduce uh uh figures uh
just one point on the parking um that
you know perhaps obviously the parking
review has been going on for quite a bit
now if that had been sort of carried out
by now that could have been included to
reduce some of the the fees
um well uh I think our Administration is
very happy that we're starting the
parking review and I think uh it has
taken quite a while um so we're happy to
announce that that process has started
and uh uh unlike the previous
administration uh uh we're getting
underway with that and hopefully by the
time next budget we'll uh uh we'll be in
a way to uh take that into account for
our fuse and charges
thanks
yeah I'll refrain from commenting on
that one I think uh councelor Wing thank
you I'm on parking as well I seem to
remember at last year's uh full council
meeting when we uh when we approved last
year's budget I asked we were told that
it was around traffic management and I
see here it is we we we increased
parking charges to manage traffic flow I
do remember at that meeting asking to
see the evidence I mean I've been now
been in in in in my role four years four
and a bit years and each year parking
charges have gone up uh and I'd like to
see the evidence behind that reasoning
of traffic management or managing
traffic flow because it's utterly failed
in central Harbor uh and so I'm I'm
making that request again that you know
for the last four years we've increased
parking charges to manage traffic flow
and I'd like to see the evidence
particularly in my my own Ward uh to the
the evidence-based decision making there
uh I also I I'd like to support the uh
the comment that's just been previously
made would then would it not be wise to
suspend an increase in parking charges
and wait for the re the the parking
strategy review which I am so glad is
happening and I don't place blame about
its delay anywhere I'm just glad it's
happening and so our
residents uh prior to lockdown it was
one of the main issues that residents
had and we had a number of meetings and
some of those meetings continued out in
the open once lockdown unlocked and the
residents were coming up with some
really really super Solutions and they
also know what the concerns
are uh parking I spent two weeks walking
my own Ward uh following discussions
with uh my residents and actually
completed a highway Improvement plan
because it was a document that gave me
some structure to review what was
happening and I can tell you that we're
not managing traffic flow by increasing
parking charges we're actually forcing
people out of our car parks and our on
street parking and onto Pavements we we
there are numerous roads in central
Harbor where people with mobility issues
uh parents or or people with uh dogs
can't access the streets because both
sides of the road a pavement are being
taken up by parked cars so uh my plea is
and I get another crack of the whip over
scrutiny is can we delay this because I
believe the residents will come up with
a whole series of of uh of ways to
manage traffic and improve things for
residents and businesses but also
generate us an
income uh the other thing I'd like to
ask is I know we we we we charge events
for suspending parking Bays is there any
chance uh we can have that figure for
last year I won't go any further back
cuz I do think the suspending parking
bays and charging events actually
creates real difficulties for our for
our our event organizers many of them
are not paid and volunteers and those
events actually generate income for for
our for our town and it was nice to hear
uh a counselor mention the the impact of
of events and the way we need to support
them in at the last council meeting so
there they a plea to suspend the
increase and wait for the parking
strategy to be completed and also a
better understanding of how how much we
actually make uh from suspending parking
bays and and charging events thank you
yeah thank you councelor Wing I mean I
look forward to to to hearing further
from from you on the subject of uh not
increasing the parking for the time
being and clearly we would have all
liked the parking review to be done a
lot earlier but
I I'm not going to get into the
political blame game of why that didn't
happen it would be better if it had been
done and it could have been factored
into this year's budget but that's not
where we are um I'm sure that when you
make a proposal if you do to um uh
suspend any increase in parking charges
you'll also be bringing forward
proposals to cut 118,000 in revenue from
the budget and obviously there will be a
corresponding ruction in the decre
income as well um I don't know if
anybody can help coun Mr sanon can you
help on on traffic flow so two things
the bit about traffic flow in terms of
the statement that's in the report is
taken slightly out of context so with
regards to setting new fees associated
with parking they you have to take into
consideration traffic flow one of the
things that we can do and have authority
do Under the road traffic tax is
increase our fees exponentially to cover
inflationary increases and such which is
why the increase is only in line with
inflation and doesn't take into account
new charging that is what you are asking
to come out of effectively the strategy
the strategy will review those things in
totality and potentially then drive the
income and associated with it and the
traffic management issues that you're
talking about so this budget doesn't
assume anything in relation to traffic
flowing in that way because there are no
new charges factored in for that purpose
so that's the first bit the bit with
regards to events we have no choice with
a suspending Bays because the majority
of the events when you're talking about
it are on street so if they're on if
they're on street for example we have no
choice the money is not ours per se
we're collecting it on behalf of KCC so
that would have an impact on DM and if
we start reducing the amount set as side
for DM we would then end up funding it
and like the leader said with regards to
reducing fees if we don't cover
inflationary increases we have to absorb
that cost so automatically over 8,000
impact on the base budget so I think
that effectively covers all your bits
because the rest will come out of that
strategy when when that's produced and
taken
forward on the suspended parking Bay so
I know of at least one event where
unpaid parking Bays were suspended and a
charge was going to be fixed so no money
would have been lost by us because no
there was no fee they they you know the
the hour the bay where you stay free for
an hour uh and you got to move and and
there was a charge put to the event on
those
unpaid parking Bays so I think Council
wi if you've got a specific example and
you send us details of it we can look
into it I will do I don't think in the
context of the budget it's something
that we can tackle tonight okay I'm sure
we'll look at specific examples and I do
have I do understand the concern of
events organizers about the cost of
parking char Oles um but it's a complex
a complex subject it's not just a
question of the council um trying to
bring in extra money it's to do with
loss Council
Gates yeah thank you councilor wiing um
I'd just um like to highlight in the
report it mentions that um income raised
through on street parking charges must
only be spent on highways and parking
related services and is shared with Kent
County Council so there a neutral effect
on our budget um so again there's
um it's not as simple as it first seems
because we have that relationship with
Ken County Council um and um I think on
on the events side um we as cabinet are
aware that we need to be very careful as
a council when setting uh events uh
parking charges to make sure they are
found responsible so uh happy to take up
that case if it's a specific one thanks
I did read that thank you Council
Yates
thank you uh members any further
comments um I do I did just want to say
that um we all recognize that it would
have been more satisfactory if we were
able to bring the uh full list of fees
and charges to this meeting as would
normally have happened unfortunately I
think you understand the reason we've
not been able to is because we've tried
to respond to the falling inflation for
the benefit of our residents and I think
that's what we should be doing so we
will bring them forward um at the
cabinet meeting at the end end of um
January and it's perfectly
understandable if there are specific
things that people want to raise at that
meeting which they've not been able to
raise tonight and we'll create some
latitude around that though I have to
say that that's building up to be a very
long count uh cabinet meeting having
seen the agenda so something to look
forward
to right members do we
agree I should have said what the what
what we're agreeing to consider the fees
and charges as set out and agree to
receive an updated schedule is meeting
on the 25th of January to form the basis
of the recommendation to council for
approval so we've agreed it item 9 the
draft 20245 budget Council Yates thank
you leader um I'm very pleased to be
able to present a balanced budget for
2024 25 to Cabinet tonight first of all
I'd like to pay thanks to our officers
from across the council and particular
our finance officers for their hard work
getting us to this point the budget
process kicked off in August 2023 with a
series of prioritization meetings and
I'm pleased to report that we have in my
view a compassionate Progressive and
Resident focused budget for all of us to
review tonight a planned approach to
budget setting combined with an
effective use of resources has allowed
us to present this budget which allows
for investment in key service areas that
contribute towards our corporate
priorities as well as helping to deliver
against what residents want as reflected
in the feedback from our resident survey
this year's Financial settlement was
broadly in line with our basic
assumptions with little no change from
what was presented in October however
the uncertainty the the certainty of a
settlement has now allowed us to review
these assumptions this has freed up some
capacity with this we are going to
employ two further graffiti cleaning
operatives in 2425 together with
equipment and transport the cost of
which will be
80,000 over over and above the
investment above we have cons we have
considered the use of glyphosate as the
principal chemical means by which to
control the presence of Weeds on land
within our ownership this Council
currently applies glyphosate using Rel
relative safe spotting method and it is
important to note that Kent County
Council also use glyphosate in spray
form to control weeds on the highways
and we understand that they will
continue to do so as a as a result of
concerns expressed about its use uh
we'll be utilizing hot foam control of
weeds in the coming year the hot foam
equipment can also be used to clean
graffiti and chewing gum from walls and
Pavements the additional cost of this
will be
£100,000 Sports Development recent
conversations with the Kent Football
Association have been positive about
funding that could be available through
them to increase the work we do with
local communities and their access to
Sport and Facilities this includes
potential support for pitch improvements
of Jackie Bakers for 2425 football
season a one of sum of £50,000 is
therefore included to be drawn down from
reserves as required pending an
application for grant
funding and lastly given the inflation
has been reduced reducing over the past
few months we are where possible
reducing our resident focused fees and
charges to no more than 5% as part of
the overall budget setting process we
will seek to update the schedule of
proposed fees and charges for 2425 in
the annex the fees and charges report in
time for the meeting of cabinet on the
25th of January 24 for recommendation to
council for approval in February however
given the time scales of the
announcement of the provisional
settlement only just before Christmas
and the latest reduction in cpri
announced on December 20 on the December
20th it will not be possible to update
the schedule in time for the meeting of
the OV and scrutiny panel the main areas
covered by this review will be parking
Garden waste waste bin replacement and
the crematorium therefore in this report
you will see that
£16,000 has been allocated for the
reduction of the fees and charges I move
these
recommendations thank you councelor
yikes do you have a second councelor
Dorth and speaking under 20.1 councelor
Davis thank you chair um again coming
back to the Porton Harbor I got a couple
of questions which um uh relate to this
to the dredging budget that's been added
in of
180,000 um it's quite clear that the
Porton Harbor need dredging because the
September figures alone show that the
maximum depth in the ports about 3.1 M
below dayam which should be nearer 7 m
and in fact vessels couldn't get in even
if they arrived at the moment bretts are
even having to offload off of low uh
reduced load vessels otherwise they
can't get into the Porton Harbor that in
itself justifies the spending of 180,000
I guess otherwise we're just going to
have a big beach there however in 2021
this Council uh set us an agreed uh
procurement process for two dredging
contracts to avoid this um what I'd like
to know because on the previous table I
saw this 180,000 was coming from
borrowing it said it does say it's going
to be made as a one-off reserve
allocation so I guess it's being
borrowed from reserves but why is that
necessary when there was in
2021 a budget approved and there seems
to have been no follow through on that
on that procurement of those two
contracts it also means that we have
been misled when we're told that the
Porton Harbor are open for business
because they're clearly not the Royal
Harbor in places is down to 2.1 M and
1.5 m in the Inner Harbor um which is
why there's no vessels of any size down
there um I want to bring this to the
leader as portfolio H and cabinets
attention for future for future
consideration obviously but also is this
money being borrowed how is it being
borrowed and why is it being borrowed
because as I say three years ago there
was a substantial budget set aside for
uh a procurement process to award four
and fiveyear contracts to to stop this
exact situation
thank you councelor Davis I mean you'll
understand that that we don't have any
Maritime officers present this evening
and um I think that you make valid
points but perhaps you'd like to make
them um to a possibly to a scrutiny
meeting or a future meeting where there
is somebody from Maritime who's able to
give you definitive answers I don't know
whether Mr Sanam can offer any any
insight into the contractual
arrangements so there was a contract
left for dredging and there is still
maintenance dredging that's undertaken
at the port and harbor on a regular
basis it's not that dredging has stopped
in totality I can't comment on the
depths and that's something that Mike
Humber would have to um comment on with
regards to how much dredging has taken
place there is still a budget within the
port and harbor for maintenance dredging
it's never been removed it was reduced
um several years ago but not in 2021 so
when the contract was L when you say a
significant sum it would have taken into
consideration the base budget as it
stood at that particular time and
grossed it up for the life of the
contract so you were probably referring
to the fact there was around 00,000 set
aside for dredging that's because that
was four years worth of Maintenance
dredging at the port and harbor this is
an additional £180,000 worth of dredging
that's required to reinstate maintenance
dredging um it was never referred to as
borrowing so I don't know what's gone
wrong there it is always been a
contribution from reserves it was part
of what was considered as as part of the
Star Chamber that 180 is to give us the
opportunity to bridge the gap for next
year to make a decision about the
long-term future of dredging and what
that will look like moving forward and
and therefore like you say whether a
contract needs to be left for a greater
value at which point that would be
factored in as a base budget at that
particular moment time reinstating it
back to its original levels if that
makes sense thank thank with your
permission chair thank you Matt that
it's explained as much as it can from
that side I do fully understand that it
needs the the maritime people but thank
you for Indulgence I also wanted to
raise it for the attention of the
cabinet and CMT rather than just throw
this in at overview and scrutiny next
week so I'm sure we'll go and and talk
about it councelor D that would be very
nice to know thank you leader uh
councelor
rattigan thank you chair uh well it's
very nice to see after a careful
conservative Administration that the
reserves have been built to be able to
cushion the the budget
holds um what I still I'm concerned
about is even though we've got a healthy
reserves I don't want it to be like when
my wife go shopping that because there's
you know a large amount of money in the
bank she has to spend the lot um I'm
just concerned at the amount of money
that's been spent and obviously I know
the services the that have been added on
there's quite a lot of money coming from
the
reserves um thank you for that councilor
vagan I mean I would point out that I
think the reserve position in the paper
goes back to
2016 um I haven't done the maths I think
conservatives have been in control of
this Council for three of those 8 years
so perhaps it's a bit much to claim all
the credit for the returns of the
reserves um councilor
Yates um well I would like to uh thank
you for pointing out our strong
financial position when it comes to
reserves uh this is a 10year high in our
reserves and double what they were in
2016 um I can't comment on shopping
behavior of uh your relatives but uh um
we as as previously highlighted in the
meeting when it comes to housing um
every one of our projects is
independently uh assessed and those um
assessments are brought in front of
cabinet um and to the public uh every
time and as far as um uh this budget's
going is concerned this budget's
concerned we think it's uh even whilst
um contributing to reserves we are
employing more
staff um we're doing the right thing on
environment we're doing the right thing
for our own staff at TDC and uh this is
exactly what the residents are asking us
to do as shown on the resident survey so
we think uh we're giving the residents
exactly what they're asking for um thank
you members any
comments
sh okay so cabinet has asked um that the
outcome of the budget consultation be
noted that the dra draft 2024 general
fund Revenue budget as amended from the
original draft of consultation be
considered and noted that the 2024 28
general fund Capital program as amended
be considered and noted and the cabinet
agrees the flexible use of receipts
policy as attached do members agreed
agre thank you and before I close the
meeting um I think whenever we talk
about the budget we ought to recognize
the hard work that goes into into it
from officers across the council um
including Chris blandel who's not not
here this evening
um and thank all members and officers
for all their input to the process not
just in finance but also in other areas
of the council where difficult choices
have had to be made I think that we've
got a good budget to put before the
council I'm delighted that we're able to
um provide an expansion in um Street
cleansing services and services to
tackle graffiti because I think
residents want that I think we all know
it's needed um and I'm proud that we're
bringing this forward as a labor
Administration
that concludes the business of tonight's
meeting I declare the meeting closed
at
7:44 and the live stream of the meeting
will now end thank
Youk